folks Joe DeRosa from the taste buds
podcast here right now saying I have
live dates coming up I want to thank all
of the fans for coming out and selling
out so many of the shows it's been truly
amazing and there's more to come I am
going to be in Houston Texas doing my
new hour at the come and take it
festival later on in this fine month of
November in December I will be a coastal
creative in St Petersburg Florida
running that same new one-man show I'll
also be doing a special live episode of
we'll see you in hell the podcast I do
with my dear friend Patrick Walsh in
January I'll be in Austin Texas at the
Vulcan and then at Governors out in Long
Island go to jodarosainfo.com for all
show information and tickets come on out
and please visit us here at Joey Rose's
come to
joeyrosesnyc.com for all Joey Rose's
information you can order online you can
come in you can drink all day you can
eat all day we are open now seven days a
week at 11 30 a.m every single day
that's joeyrosesnyc.com all right guys
the Impractical Jokers are back on the
road after three years we just announced
the tour is called the drive drive drive
tour tickets are available
impracticaljokerslive.com all cities
across the country we start off in
Pittsburgh at the PPG Paints Arena we'll
be coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island so
on and forth so forth everything's on
sale right now and then uh that starts
in February before that my only two
months left to touring are November and
December November uh 11th Knoxville
November 12th two in Atlanta Georgia one
just sold out says you want to get
tickets get it to the second show 13th
November 13th in Alabama and then we got
November 18th in Louisville and November
19th in Evansville December will be
California and Florida check it all out
right now at savocanocomedy.com
everything's on sale merch is available
there for everything pick up some merch
I'll see you on the road they come into
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like
howdy Tasties and taste buddies welcome
to
t-a-s-d-e buds I'm doing the chat solo
because Salvo Cano's not here where do
you think he is in this moment in times
uh uh pimp where do you think Sal is I
my vote is he is currently
uh feeding somebody mayonnaise but it's
actually marshmallow on camera and then
they all have a good laugh about the
wild pranket that it all was
uh
grocery store yeah
right now shall can't be with us he's
diving head first into a pile of manure
in a something or other
mommy on his cheek and a bear isn't it
coming towards him right now I I Sally's
shooting I'm just kidding I love Sal I
love the Jokers they're but they're they
suck happier today because he's shooting
uh but I'm back again with two wonderful
guests and two dear friends of mine
Robert Kelly and cuisine
I don't what's up what's up what's up
hello uh Pete please folks if you're
watching the show and you like the show
the show excuse me oh it's repeating on
me I would like you to please subscribe
please like the episodes
and check out our merch uh you can get
our merch at what is the merch website
pimp
all right it's in the description just
look down at the description everything
he needs down in that description
there's your like button there's your
subscribe button there's your merch link
because you can leave a nice comment
and yes I am wearing some of the merch
to taste buds socks it was a class thank
you very much you're wearing the miss
we got some some fans in the in the RV
today we're here at Joey roses in our
outdoor space our outdoor IV RV not Ivy
uh we got some fans down there thanks
for coming in everybody
it's all women down there
a couple guys a couple guys
but I don't know you guys have got your
hair is long enough good looking fans
man huh you got good looking fans it's
nice isn't it you ever seen my fans yeah
oh
looks like a bunch of iron workers that
got laid off
that's the women
listen your fans have hope and youth in
their eyes look at it the guy right
there looks like he has his own band
the guy after him he's got his own
little.com he's starting off where he
makes his own soap
oh my God what a good looking people you
got they got good energy yeah it's good
energy that's my fan right there that
old lady with the Walker and the hat oh
my God that's a grocery thing you know I
bring one of those to the market no you
don't yes they do Jesus Christ
let me tell you why can I tell you why
because you could fit 42 quarter pounds
in there no no you know why I do it yeah
we know my Supermarket gives you bags
with no handles oh the paper base yeah
so you can't if you want to do a big
show buddy if you want to do a big shop
you can't get you can't get the bag how
are you supposed to carry it get the
grocery bag get your own
that's I got too much get a duffel bag
like a man no I bring that thing dude
you wheel that thing right home it's
just dude get it backpack throw the [ __ ]
in the back put on your back it's not a
backpack's not big enough talking about
the big shopping get a big backpack yeah
you know you could do that in Manhattan
oh dude I got a full Metro acre
Supermarket
day to day and you're gonna go to
different places for meat right
different places for bread different
places for these things there's no
grocery store in Manhattan that has
everything that's good you're gonna go
to different spots I have a full size
Suburban style supermarket in my
neighborhood I'm telling you it's called
Metro Acres it is a full Supermarket
there's no way Deli counter Seafood
counter everything no way why would I
lie to you about that I don't know you
make this show interesting we'll fight
about it all right fair enough
anyway
uh folks today we're battling cold
sandwiches versus hot sandwiches this is
something that I
I guess secretly or subconsciously
wanted to do and didn't realize how much
I wanted to do it and then couge you
kind of suggested it when we were going
back and forth about what should we
battle when you come on the show
and I was like oh yeah like why have we
never done that like that's like yes
it's this is a great argument I'm very
excited I am team cold sandwich
Team Hot you're Team Hot I'm I'm team
hot too buddy all right great I'll take
you both on yeah all right you're gonna
lose
I don't give a [ __ ] we got too much ammo
dude a cold
cold sandwich ain't even a minute hold
on hold on we're not in the battle yet
yeah let me steer the ship here you
relax the uh yeah some of the fans are
chiming in they want to see you get
salty
uh oh well listen you guys are welcome
to do the chants with me
we do two chants all right guys
sometimes it gets a little too heated
with me and Sal so we would do a chant
where we just go no matter what happens
I love you three times okay I'll do it
and that would let us know that no
matter what happened in the Battle
everything will be fine okay but then on
other days when we want a little more
spice yeah because we feel a little too
calm yeah which I kind of feel right now
yeah you're very relaxed
so are you we do another chant where we
go it's time to get salty it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty and
then you launch immediately into an
insult at the other guy and it'll get
your blood going let's go let's do that
one I'll do that yeah very personal let
me do it ready so here's how it works we
say It's Time against all these three
times and then you immediately fired but
it's got I'm in a fast insole and then I
do it right back to you yeah ready yeah
out of this one you lock eyes all right
let's lock eyes ready here we go one
one two three it's time to get salty
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty your socks are too short see all
right
all right ready yeah it's time to get
salty it's time to get suicide it's time
to get something it's time to get
something it's time to get salty the new
size of your head bothers me
I don't like a compliment itself is the
worst
I like that all right here we go it's
time to
b-a-t-t-l-e budge we're in I am team
cold sandwiches bring it on boys I'll
give you opening argument on why hot
sand which is Big cold sandwich all
right well hot sandwiches meal coldest
before people no offense
I mean I couldn't think of a better way
to I mean that's the argument we could
stop right there it's for it's for poor
people all right yeah oh my God yeah we
got in the morning bacon egg and cheeses
egg sandwiches boom what do you want to
do right lunch
what do we got we got [ __ ] you can't
even download
BLT BLT says
do you want a BLT it's [ __ ] the best
meat one of the times in the world your
BLT
and then name a BLT it's expensive these
days pal all right so so long and then
and then dinner go dinner go chicken
Palm any Palm yeah all right all right
okay
we're not gonna count po boys you have
cold well no it's not half cold it's not
a [ __ ] okay then I'll climb it is a
sandwich
it's lettuce your socks suck
let's go
let's go tremonts oh you're nuts dude
that's like saying a Cheesesteak Hoagie
counts as a hot sandwich it does not she
does not a cheesecake is hot a
Cheesesteak Hoagie I said
it's a cheese steak made like a hoagie
it's hot it's half cold half hot okay
you [ __ ] suck mental patience
sandwich at me right now a chicken Palm
okay okay
the [ __ ] sauces and peppers
sausage and peppers will blow any
[ __ ] stupid cold sandwich out of the
game you know what I like a cold sausage
and pepper cause you're a poor person
you can't get it when it's hot you can't
get it when it's hot when we afford to
get it when it comes out off the grill
into the bum You Gotta Wait hey you want
this here you I'm not gonna finish this
you said in the last episode you had the
prank call and say sandwich it because
you were so broke what are you talking
about I would never ever eat a cold hot
sandwich I'm not that much of a piece of
[ __ ] please dude please a cold sock
first of all you eat a cold sausage and
pepper the peppers and onions are
congealed and the oil hardens up you're
a [ __ ] sign you know what you're
talking about
yeah what do you got for cold
let me first of all retort to what you
opened with bacon egg and cheese chicken
egg and cheese anybody that feels the
need to eat a [ __ ] sandwich at 8 30
a.m are you out of your mind period what
do you eat here dude first of all he
saved me some [ __ ] fruit maybe some
you're a fruit like a human being you're
hitting dinner before [ __ ] soda like
a [ __ ] man like a man first of all
we need a bigger meal not like you who
wakes up at noon we get up and do [ __ ]
we need energy what do you think he
needs energy to do to go review [ __ ]
cannolis in his car what do you think it
does all day
he drives from shop to shop scamming
them for free food so he can go [ __ ] his
car and go hey I gave it four morons I
should have got this for free can we
chant this I don't [ __ ] like you I
don't like you I don't like you how's
that first of all when you have a hot
sandwich he he breakfast lunch dinner
all night long late night you your cold
sandwich lunch only kid [ __ ] lunch
only oh [ __ ] lunch only [ __ ] what what
are you gonna do you can't wake up and
have them tell me you can't have a
corned beef special for dinner you're
telling me that's hot no it's not hot no
it's not life is hot hot sometimes it's
hotter corn beef special is not a hot
sandwich it's got cold cheese cold uh
dressing and cold coleslaws it's hot
it's hot the protein is hot the main
looking the parameter the main [ __ ]
dish turkey club is a dinner sandwich
don't you [ __ ] tell me about my head
dude what's up buddy real quick with Tom
sharpley was on the show two weeks ago
he was going like this he was going
Joe you think that and I go put that
[ __ ] claw down and I cited you I go
Bobby Kelly you should help me for
putting those fingers
those [ __ ] Harry Potter wands that
come right at you and it bothers me yeah
good point here about what it looks like
Joe
in seven years
[Laughter]
that's very funny
that's very funny
you you don't get sick in seven years
there I look like I just recovered from
something
like I'm not sick now but I could come
back dude you pieces of [ __ ] I hope you
all choke on a sandwich the by the way
the fact that he called a BLT a hot
sandwich I know why he did listen it's
not it's not nuts it's hot bacon and
he's talking about a BLT not with threes
we're talking overloaded bacon
overloaded bacon if you get a BLT and
you don't ask for extra bacon you're not
a good person I argued BLT on this show
I love a blp it is not a hot sandwich
when you bite into it it's hot no it's
not it's warm it best at best let me
know it's [ __ ] hot in my book
when you get a steak at night right when
you go to a steak restaurant do they
call it a steak potatoes and green bean
restaurant what do they call it a steak
restaurant what the [ __ ] are you like
just answer my question yeah go ahead do
they call it a steakhouse should they
okay they don't call it a a steak
potatoes green beans house they call it
a steakhouse because the main [ __ ]
thing you're getting is the steak are
you getting potatoes and a vegetable yes
I want to congratulate you and I say
this for my own personal experience for
making the most asinine argument this
podcast has ever happened
[Music]
quality I think it's quality what is you
but what is your point my point is that
not everything in the sand would try to
be not everything in the sandwiches the
same place when you're talking about
when you're talking about cold
ingredients outweighing the hot
ingredient you've got a cold sandwich or
it's at least off the table
can't easily [ __ ]
I really can't go by come on okay listen
to me I know DeRosa don't let him get
you weak stay with me we got him on the
ropes trust you already won yeah
listen the turkey club is a go-to in any
diner and a go-to for dinner in any
diner I hate to hear something you can't
eat you can eat an Italian sub for
dinner you can't eat it for breakfast
you can't eat it you can't eat a turkey
sandwich we're in a [ __ ] America
buddy you go go to Holland go to the
Netherlands mayonnaise
look at this kid I like him this kid's
never been picked he's never been
passive Arizona he's a goddamn True
Blood American he doesn't [ __ ] deal
you gotta go to another country like a
Trader to make your point we're staying
right here in America playing the
sandwiches yeah we believe in God and in
this country you go oh you go to the UK
socks belong in the UK
you go to the UK yes you go to the
Netherlands you go to the breakfast
buffets and stuff that they have the
hotel let me tell you yeah prosciutto
salami uh cheese and that is a staple
what else do they have is it honestly
what else do they have they have a lot
of stuff too but stop making it sound
like you can't have a cold meat at
breakfast well saying when you get a
sandwich that's first of all that's not
a sandwich it's a [ __ ] charcuterie
thing you get it listen it's not a
sandwich but the bacon is in is in a
sandwich either at that thing but you
can take whatever you take on a cold
sandwich all the stuff the lettuce the
tomatoes all the [ __ ] that makes it
cold you can put that on you're telling
me for breakfast you've never eaten or
couldn't eat or couldn't fathom eating a
thinly sliced prosciutto with a little
mutz and some some uh basil and tomato
for breakfast you'd think that breakfast
you take that where are you where but
why wouldn't you eat that for breakfast
because I'm not meant what's your bagel
with cream cheese if you're not mentally
what go ahead and shape get yourself
lose everything right now and one thing
I can snip and post it you're not
mentally what
[Music]
[Laughter]
mentally you had it mentally it was the
way to say it yeah wait what so that's
[ __ ] lunch buddy if you did like
bonjour what's an egg on a sandwich what
if that's breakfast but yeah you can't
[ __ ] cold cuts for breakfast you can
you're going with just cold cuts which
you're talking tuna you're talking
chicken salad cold Subs you're giving
them ideas over here sandwiches yeah but
you don't wake up and have a cold
sandwich I'll give you this a tuner in
the morning I'll give you this I'll give
you this you've you got guys have it at
breakfast you're right if you have a
sandwich at breakfast time and dinner
hold on stop let me just say this you've
you've got you got sandwiches locked
down at breakfast I'll give you that
lunch time I rule the roost and I will
tell you why I'll tell you why because a
hot sandwich at lunch puts you down
you're too tired nobody works anyway
anyway so what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I might as well eat a hot meal
don't make me feel good about myself but
you know what I'm saying though you eat
a hot sandwich at lunch you're tired
dude you're like I want to go to bed I
feel like I just say four slices of
pizza right now that's what I do every
day I wake out of bed at 11 o'clock
bacon egg and cheese 1 30. a nice
sausage and peppers yeah nice and then
you take a little nap you're gonna die
dude I hope so
your cold theories things because it's
one time a day you can really enjoy
dinner go ahead too it is not dinner too
you can say it as many times as you want
uh you cannot eat a [ __ ] tuna fish
sandwich at dinner if my wife said hey
what are we having for dinner tonight
tuna I'd leave the voice but my point is
is you go into a diner you can't get a
turkey club for dinner you wouldn't eat
an Italian sub that's different no no no
that's hot on it no it doesn't has bacon
is hot stop okay Bob that is a cold
sandwich and you know it stop it
stop it
stop it that is insane [ __ ] that they
toast the bread so it's got to be hot
where is that [ __ ] rat Finance he's
out there she's out there
come in here look at him showing up
trying to get his way onto the pod
what a little mooch come here yeah see
look at him cheering he got included
yeah yeah yes you did I told you I
called you on the phone and said I'm
doing my podcast I thought you'd be
inside you didn't know you didn't know
it was a production
I'm a big fan thank you Joe not so much
because he likes cold sandwiches yeah
wait wait Ian Shadow this just just one
yes or no wait I'm a paying customer I
just got through your delicious Sam
thank you very much they're fantastic
thank you very much name the answers
question is a turkey club a cold or a
hot sandwich thank you what if they
toast the bread
what if the Bacon's fresh what if the
Bacon's fresh hot right off the ground
it's fresh it's even more delicious but
it's not a hot sandwich when it's a
whole thing's toasted or toasted bread
with hot bacon are you cooking it all at
the same time sure why not no no no no
[ __ ] what are we doing here I'm
treating the whistle Witnesses hostile
all right I mean you were really going
out on a limb and with yourself it's
breaking
I'm sorry that I was trying to get a
laugh you look good Bobby you know go
[ __ ] yourself I hope you choke on your
cold sandwich you think you think that's
what he's choking on oh yeah how do you
think I'm paying for the sandwiches
this kid just came from a hole around
the corner
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much folks let's talk about our
sponsor Miracle brand I love it Miracle
brand helping you stay cool at night and
sleep in the right way I gotta tell you
people I am somebody that runs hot when
I sleep I need the right temperature I
love what Miracle brand is doing by
using silver infused bed sheets all
right that were inspired by NASA
temperature at night could have one of
the greatest impacts on your sleep if
you're too hot if you're too cold
it can screw you up that's why I highly
recommend Miracle brand and their
product for what they're doing you got
to get a good night's sleep and if the
temp is off people you're miserable
that's just all that there is to it in
the morning you want to feel good when
you wake up these sheets have self
cooling properties self cooling
properties for a better quality sleep
again
it's a silver infused fabric originally
developed by NASA they're also
self-cleaning which is great the sheets
are infused with natural silver as I
said and that prevents 99.9 of bacteria
growth leaving them to stay clean and
fresh three times longer than other
sheets
hygiene a good thing you're going to go
to trimirical.com tastebuds again that's
trimirical.com taste buds maybe you want
a product for yourself maybe you want to
give it as a gift for the holiday season
but you're going to get a deal
you're going to save over 40 off when
you use promo code taste buds and then
you're also going to get three free
towels I don't know how much better this
could get it's a great deal again go to
try miracle.com tastebuds use the promo
code taste buds claim your free
three-piece towel set and get 40 over 40
off my God almighty this is just come on
folks again try miracle.com taste buds
three free towels save over 40 percent
treat yourself or a friend or both
during this holiday season
folks I want to talk about a newer
sponsor native native
that's right when it comes to hygiene
the time
to read a laundry list of ingredients on
the back of your personal care product I
know I don't and I don't feel like doing
it and when I do do it I don't even know
what half of the damn things are native
personal care products all right these
are thoughtfully formulated to keep you
feeling and smelling fresh all day long
all right
while you can also care about what's
going into your body because native is
aluminum free deodorant they keep their
ingredient list bare naked ingredients
you understand when you're reading them
like coconut oil shea butter baking soda
you see what I'm saying I really really
like this deodorant I've been using it
for the last week or so it's got 72 hour
protection naturally derived ingredients
and a smooth residue free application I
really like that I hate when you put on
deodorant and it gets white stuff on
your shirt it drives me crazy also what
I like about Native is that it works a
lot of the time you get natural
deodorant stuff and it doesn't work you
smell native again making you feel fresh
making you smell fresh they have awesome
scents
uh let me read you some of these wild
combos warm cider and cinnamon cashmere
and Rain I've been using that one it's
it smells really good it's I like to
smell myself to be honest with you
toasted marshmallow and vanilla Wild
Wood so folks try native smell fresh
feel fresh all day long you're gonna go
to nativedo.com taste buds or you can
just use the promo code taste buds at
checkout again that's native
deo.com taste buds or just use the promo
code taste buds at checkout and you are
going to get 20 off your first order
check it out folks enjoy
I heard your little BLT conversation all
right it's not a hot sandwich that's
what I eat that's right bacon is hot
yeah that's the main part of the
sandwich no there's lettuce tomato and
Mayo flipped as soon as I said what does
it mean if I gave you a BLT without the
bacon what would you do I'd still eat it
if I gave you a sandwich with just bacon
would you be happy would you be happy
answer the question would you be happy
with the bacon yes then shut up the
Bacon's the main thing but the bacon
if you have lettuce [ __ ] sandwich no
offense vegetarians I know you like that
[ __ ] but it's bacon Bacon's the god
that's it and you're fat too I know I
put on weights someone asked the other
night if I had two calls and four
sandwiches but they're good that one
well I need to eat later
the uh anyway this has been taste buds
everybody
dude I'm sorry [ __ ] call me chubby
and I didn't like it I know I'm sorry I
don't like your socks
you don't like his socks either he
doesn't have socks I stole them this is
too short though
uh uh listen Ian's input is valuable and
I think it's fair that we take it a
turkey club is a cold sandwich yeah
first of all right when he was like I'll
take both of you [ __ ] on myself I got
it then he's got to get reinfo I
guarantee texted this son of a [ __ ] and
I need your help
I am an unbiased voice no you're bi yeah
I put the Buy in bias you're a hundred
percent
listen to me
I will tell you where cold sandwiches
take the cake I will tell you where they
take the cake everything you're saying
is fine and dandy until you're at home
and you got to make it yourself nothing
beats what the [ __ ] makes a sandwich at
home oh come on you don't make
sandwiches and you're the cooker guy
neither do you you came down here to get
three of them but I'm not known for
fruit when you gotta go to the fridge
for lunch when you gotta when you gotta
go to the fridge for lunch or you
getting late and you don't feel like
cooking and you go to the fridge
a cold sandwich is the move and you know
it
you know why you know why do you know
why again back to my friend's Point
you're poor you don't have the money no
if you're a meal you think you think
[ __ ] eat uh Elon Musk is going making
a ham sandwich for lunch no he's getting
whatever the he's getting a chicken Palm
delivered to [ __ ] the Tesla Factory
hey and he's what he is not poor he
threw a pig roast here for his birthday
and made everyone pay that is a sign of
a good businessman
you made everybody pay yes for your
birthday talking to my birthday pink
rose by the way bring a song we gave
listen a song yeah hold on let me be
clear about something
I didn't pay yeah let me be clear by the
way we know
yeah let me clear about something we
gave a shitload we gave a shitload of
free drinks away it's not my fault he
has a terrible [ __ ] problem and
couldn't enjoy any of the whiskey that
was seven and a half years sober and
guess what that saved me money
for more sandwiches yeah there you go
there you go seven and a half years
[ __ ] sober this kid he couldn't enjoy
any of the free [ __ ] we gave away since
when he gave away free sandwiches at a
[ __ ] birthday party give away free
drinks have you ever been to a birthday
party and they're like hey there's Pizza
have you ever been to a business yeah
you can't call it a birthday party and a
business I did it thank you
you throw yourself you're the only guy I
know that throws his own birthday
parties did I throw a birthday party I
said we're roasted a pig at Joey roses
and yeah we showed up and you had an
apple in your mouth
dude I think you may have texted I'm
having a birthday party no I said for my
birthday we're hanging out at the bar my
birthday that's your birthday party it
doesn't mean everything's free there it
does where you invite somebody to be a
birthday party what did you charge them
for the cake till you caught up we gave
away so much free booze it was not about
the booze you give away the food people
will pay for the booze you don't give
away free [ __ ] bougie giveaway free
food never heard of an open [ __ ] join
us it's Joey roses for liftoff a
lunchtime party that's the wrong invite
stupid celebrity the launch that's the
wrong yeah dummy
Jay Ian we're on your side don't [ __ ]
this up he already [ __ ] it up don't be
it don't please don't [ __ ] this up get
your [ __ ] together
all right listen let's get back to the
battle you stop with the stop just going
back to the joke of your poor I want you
to make I want you to respond to my
actual point and you know I'm right yeah
when you gotta make a sandwich at home a
cold sandwich is ruler and you know this
and this is why I hate you and the salad
sandwiches get those fingers out of my
face egg salad those are great one way
cold I'm not saying listen you're making
it that I'm saying egg salad's not great
all these things are great I do love
those things but if you the debate is
this my friend and it comes down to this
okay what is better a hot sub or a
[ __ ] cold sub and if you gave me a
choice at lunch to a sausage and peppers
or dinner whatever and an egg salad
sandwich I would take the egg salad
sandwich and mush it in your face
that's right I got distracted by the
woman carrying a full [ __ ] stereo
down the street
Christ this city I'm gonna lose my mind
I gotta move that is the greatest thing
I've ever seen in my life what do you
want to be in Idaho with the same dude
walks by every five minutes you just had
a this is culture that's the Lower East
Side Joe this is where we're at I was in
the middle explaining that Ian well I
did it in a quicker way I did it in a
funny way yeah I'll give you that I'll
be [ __ ] giving a TED Talk relax he
looks like he looks like the first guy
that gets shot every Western
yeah he does he looks like the bartender
that comes off hard and it gets slapped
in the face the weasel yeah
he'll shot an unarmed man they say that
about Ian in Unforgiven I want I want
you to start wearing a vest
I know you would yeah all right can I
just say real quick you're making a
sandwich at home if you're not toasting
the bread you're sick in the head okay
oh that's a slogan nice yeah she put
that on a shirt that's not a hot
sandwich no I'm not saying that I'm
saying toasted bread no matter what does
it make the sandwich hot but you gotta
toast what makes a sandwich a sandwich
anyone what makes the sandwich the
sandwich what gives the sandwich the
name it's in between two slices of bread
you mean hot or cold he means what makes
it hot or cold but there's food
and if I had a sausage and peppers hot
on a soft Italian roll sausage and
peppers okay and I gave it to you would
you like ketchup in it what do you like
in it mustard what do you like a hot
sandwich sausage and peppers more than
one ingredient heated up
it does not I agree it does not and
listen here's what hot means there's
more hot than cold on it here's what
cold means there's more cold than hot on
it that's fair that's fair what would
you rather have here
if I give you an egg salad sandwich at
dinner egg salad sandwich or a sausage
and peppers what would you like I'd be
like are we in prison sandwich dinner
hot sauce and pepsil okay exactly you're
a hot you're with us no we're not
getting these sandwiches cold because
you have to because he's a cold sandwich
[ __ ] that doesn't make a hot sandwich
not everything needs to be hot cold
sandwiches are awesome yeah cold
sandwiches are great we have a menu
coming out called The Leftovers menu
That's cold versions of hot sandwiches
are awesome this is what you do this is
what you [ __ ] do go ahead you [ __ ]
you you you oh it's like arguing with my
wife I didn't say because I'm right no
you mean because I regret this
relationship
because he's locked into a mortgage
he had it and you ruined it okay
they laughed rolling that's all I care
listen anyway folks let's talk about one
of my favorite sponsors better help I
love better help
you get problems in your life you get
stuck focusing on those problems and the
problem with focusing on problems is
you're not focusing on problem solving
better help is here to help they're
great they make therapy convenient it's
all done online they're gonna match you
quickly and efficiently with a therapist
that you like that you relate to that
you jive with and if you don't feel that
it's working for you anymore you can
switch therapists at any time all of it
is done on your phone or on your
computer however you want you can do
video sessions you can do phone calls
you can do this at your leisure from
your home in the method that you need to
do it getting you to the problem solving
so you can solve the problems instead of
getting stuck focusing on the problems
themselves that's just one of the great
things that better help can bring into
your life I really really like this
company
so if you want to be a better Problem
Solver as I know you do therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com taste
buds and you're going to get 10 off your
first month that's better help.com taste
buds me yeah what you're saying is that
we're saying that these other sandwiches
suck we're not saying that we're not you
just said these things we like those
sandwiches but what I just expect I did
the example I just did with the human
being over here yes is that we said
would you rather have this or that and
the majority of people would rather have
a hot sub than a cold sub not [ __ ] cold
Subs they suck which is not what we're
saying
no we're saying that a hot sub is better
than a cold sub hands [ __ ] down I
went on the street and I said you want a
sausage and peppers or do you want a
tuna fish everybody would go [ __ ] your
tuna no no no no that's not true first
of all but but I understand why where
that's coming from I will say this
and I truly believe this
I feel that a hot sub is an easier thing
to get away with and in a cold sub
you're completely exposed if your [ __ ]
is not together with a cold sand [ __ ]
sub sandwich if your [ __ ] is not
together with a cold sandwich if the
meat is not sliced properly if the right
amount of ingredients aren't balanced if
it's not your whatever you're exposed
for a bad or a good sandwich
but hold on but hot it's like oh we
melted cheese on it and we dumped right
go on it it's good enough it's good
enough like and I'm just like yeah
whatever man I had a Michelin star
restaurant I just want a sandwich just
stuff my face but but I'm saying [ __ ]
artwork
I'll take it a step further than because
that's the case without saying which is
I think that's why a lot of times more
than that a hot sandwich leaves you
feeling tired and lethargic and sick
because it's about all food should make
you feel all right well it's you know
what I'm saying though it's a lot dumped
together he's saying he likes salads
yeah
yeah we're gonna Joey Panera that's your
new nickname no I'm but I but I think
that's a fair point no it's not a fair
point why when you eat a sandwich you
want the high of being like Oh yeah
that's what you just trashed me for you
just made fun of me for saying I gotta
take a nap after I ate my cold cut combo
so now I'm switching it up to [ __ ]
make another Point that's the way these
arguments work I got another one
sandwich has so much salt on it yeah
it's disgusting no that's not true only
if you're doing the cured meats the cold
cuts every [ __ ] cold cut is drenched
in salt if it's got it good as opposed
to what Italian sausage yeah cause you
know how low in sodium that is sandwich
buddy can I say whole body
hold on freaking sounds gotta have a
shitload of salt
no that's not true look at this hey how
you doing what was that
[ __ ] lunatic who was that you
couldn't have done this Uptown
no I wanted to do it here because it's
National sandwich day no I'm talking put
your stupid shop Uptown I have my
regrets
hold on Ian hold on with your point wait
wait you but what you're saying most of
the hospital his name is not Ian but no
no I was saying to Ian over there most
of the hot foods you're talking about
are sausage loaded with sodium okay
chicken cutlet a lot of the time a lot
of salt in that really all right bacon
bacon you're hinging 90 percent of your
argument today on bacon it doesn't get
salty and that's he's so [ __ ] crazy
90 we said 90 how much have you guys
talked about bacon today a lot we talked
about sausage
get on that mic and back me up right now
I don't need pimp to back us up because
I need him
take that [ __ ] mic down you hear that
thank you pip listen this bacon talk
because they wouldn't allow bacon in his
hot [ __ ] sub no we're mainly putting
up a chicken cutlet a veal Palm a
[ __ ] sausage and peppers A meatballs
I mean you want to talk sodium dude you
the gravy they're putting on these
things is is soft too and then sugar
content making me nuts the [ __ ] to
cure a meat you know how much salt that
has to go into curing you're talking
about cure I said already if the cured
meats or what you're trying to find
that's one type of meat way worse than
anything is not like that roast beef is
not like that tuna is not like that it's
not like that there's a million cheeses
not like there's a million cold things
you could put on a sandwich cheese
sandwiches grilled cheese sandwich
winning
yes I'll take a hot grilled cheese over
that thing you gave me oh please can you
please that was pretty good though
you're a vegetarian there you go if
you're a vegetarian the fact that they
made a cheese sandwich you'd come down
to The Taste tasty and vegetarians like
it it's amazing but if you melted that
[ __ ] it'd be way better no I I I
I I I grilled cheese them on and off
with yes Ian I I think it all depends
where you're from We're from Philly and
that's the culture you're garbage people
you're right
Hoagies Subs everything is like that's
why I love Joey roses because it tastes
like Philadelphia it's [ __ ] delicious
it's like a grandmother's deli food it's
amazing I I say all that to Joe Kudos I
gotta say Bobby I think I agree BLT is
hot it the bacon thank you the bread
toasted and Warren zevonne said it best
Enjoy Every Sandwich so you can't go
wrong with whatever you get I have to go
to therapy now
um I have an appointment did you just go
right down the middle and agree with all
of us hey no what I'm saying to some
information is that if you're not
toasting the bread you're sick in the
head buy the shirts ianfinance.com thank
you oh my god shirt does he have a shirt
probably no oh you should have a shirt
what am I doing I'd wear those socks no
I but you're right about the BLT but Joe
gold sandwich is King thank you yeah
it's not King there's nothing better
than a cold sandwich with chips
who I learned that from Cosby and when
has he ever been wrong
but great thank you I love you guys love
you buddy buddy take care and Ian brings
up a great Point thanks Ian Ian brings
up a great Point guys what the ultimate
side to any sandwich goes better with
the cold than the hot chips and a pickle
is the ultimate stock and sideways we
don't need extras with a hot sandwich
the hot sandwich is it you don't need to
you exactly hot sandwich
you need chips and other [ __ ] and a
pickle to go with your dumb sandwich we
just get the sandwich and you're done
because because it's it's 2 000 calories
and you feel like oh now you're [ __ ]
bringing this into it you're thinking a
[ __ ] cold cut sandwich doesn't have a
[ __ ] one I'm not saying cold cut
sandwich the difference is 200 calories
perfect Bell for him I'm not saying he
should have that when he enters every
room
Ian just rode past on his bike and just
rang the bell hot sandwiches are higher
in calories look at the look at the
calories no that's not a fact it's
absolutely effective look at the calorie
count and any fast food place it's all
hot stuff it's not Facebook
would you get if you went to Chick-fil-A
what would you get there cold chicken
sandwich peanut butter and jelly gold
okay answer the question please just
answer this question Chick-fil-A which
we both love we both used to Pretend
We're college students to sneak into NYU
Chick-fil-A right would you get dude
this city is driving me crazy well you
put in these Village what did you want
you could have done the west side you
know what I thought in each Village I'd
get when people walk by play music good
music the third the third time today
absolutely he was cranking Celine Dion
on like a [ __ ]
on like an Alpine like bumping system go
ahead sorry
that's [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
with that comment no I am not letting
that into the arc that is ridiculous
technology
no stop it no absolutely not if you go
to Chick-fil-A what sandwich are you
getting I get the Chick-fil-A Sandwich
what is it just say what it is no
because what you said I didn't say hot
sandwiches were bad I said I like cold
sandwiches better what is it I saw that
he gave me the finger like that by the
way what is it what is it what is it
it's hot with cold
pickles no it is
awesome I love the Chick-fil-A sandwich
it's hot okay I'm not a hot guy you're a
hot guy
only in the literal sense
but in a food sector we're not we're not
talking mediocre sandwiches and cold
sandwiches
I am saying something to you and you're
not a Dr you're not responding to it I
have been responding to everything a hot
sandwich is less healthy period not true
look it up
buy a podcast you're just saying [ __ ] we
talk all the time about about that about
the health quality of a certain meal and
I will say one of the reasons I like how
hot sandwiches less is because they make
me feel shittier so [ __ ] eat Jenny
Craig for a little bit
but that's that that goes into it for me
if I'm gonna feel like [ __ ] afterwards
here we go now here we go sandwiches are
filled with preservatives that give you
cancer bang bang
sauce
you're gonna look just like me in 10
years
from your cold sandwiches enjoy that all
right
listen I'm not sitting here saying
sandwich cold sandwiches are healthy I
am saying they are yes I said they are
healthier than hot sandwiches yeah I'm
not I'm telling you right now you don't
get cancer from a chicken bomb or a
sausage
sausage is healthy yeah dude you don't
get cancer from it
no you have a heart you don't have a
heart attack it's chicken yeah sausage
sausage [ __ ] parsley in it
it's not rice
all right pip where are we at with time
we're coming to the end we're at 40. all
right can we can you okay let's let's go
to the phones and I can't we don't have
the usual setup can you feed us just a
few great comments from Twitter a lot of
people are tying the weather to what
kind of sandwich they're gonna order
that's a great point for me cold weather
or sorry for me hot weather cold
sandwich for me cold weather still cold
sandwich that's how I do it [ __ ] and you
know it that's how I do it that's
[ __ ] nonsense yeah you're a [ __ ]
life all right this is a confession
that's what I'm saying so if if it was
confession I'd be telling the truth but
it's not it's a food podcast the uh
here's the thing
which one is that the [ __ ]
great sandwich yeah and it's cold no it
wouldn't be better if it was hot it
would ruin it if it was hot if you had a
sausage Bob if you win the sausage
yeah dude if you had a chicken Palm here
a hot chicken Palm or a sausage sandwich
kind of but like sliced in half I would
never serve a chicken parm here because
it's the same old same old there's a
million Chicken parms in this city if I
serve the chicken parm it'd have a spin
on it and I will leave it at that
that was [ __ ] good I like that
writing in that uh the best combo is a
cold sandwich dipped into hot soup
that's in Portillo [ __ ] that's gross
what are you [ __ ] do you like do you
like On Golden Pond the movie yeah
that's [ __ ] gross I've never I've
never liked a [ __ ] I get furious with
a place it's like try our half a
sandwich and soup I know I'm like uh
yeah that's annoying myself all right
yeah a lot of people do we have any
funny winners in the tweets I'm reading
through them a lot of people just saying
hot sandwiches are more unhealthy that's
not true that's not a fact curious who
do you think by looking at the phones
pimp who might win this thing
a lot of people are just commenting the
toasted bread question what is a hot
sandwich what isn't a hot sandwich we
should have clarified that in the
beginning they were well they can't hear
us so it doesn't matter
you know what I mean we should have
clarified it for us yeah well I mean but
we know toasted bread does not make a
hot sandwich it's right well you can't
touch it if you can't pick it up because
it's hot it's guys it's got to be hot
you got to heat the meat up you gotta
what do you talk about a toasted
sandwich is hot
that's not true wow you could book ice
cold Tuna on a toast on toast it's not a
hot sandwich it's hot cold
that makes it a cold sandwich either
yeah that's what I said at the beginning
these in-betweeners off the table nobody
listened to me so here we are
[Music]
here we are all right pimp all right
guys anything to plug before we uh go to
the vote here
yeah yeah Robert Kelly live on Instagram
follow me you [ __ ] all you cold
sandwich people stay away
um and get my special Louis ck.com kill
box very proud of it go check it out and
uh that's it
uh yeah meows by Kush and all socials
and food reacts on the YouTube I just
got a new YouTube channel reacting to
food with my buddy Nick all right people
all right people like I support These
Guys these guys are great thanks boys
for being here for two episodes in a row
I really appreciate it it's great to see
both of you thank you uh as I said at
the top subscribe like comment review
and buy the merch please link is down
below here we go pimp what do we got
there's one more good
they said that America was built on cold
sandwiches thank you yeah they were poor
when they came immigrants they had
nothing and then they killed a bunch of
Indians and they became [ __ ] and
then we got civilized and we made hot
sandwiches another one we gotta we gotta
we got a tradition whoever wins says the
loser I still love you babe yeah and you
gotta go I love you too okay so go ahead
say it all right ready loser with 40 of
the vote is cold sandwiches yes we won
but oh you're on our sides now you're on
his side [ __ ] all of you yeah it is a
bunch of Front Runners you want to be
the winning team
yes go ahead don't quote say the goddamn
line why do I have to say because you
won I have to say it to you yes what is
it again you know how I explained it
just two seconds ago I was so excited
that we won I didn't know we're gonna
win I'm sorry about your socks
I still love you buddy is what you say
but hey look at me Joe look at me look
at me I still love you buddy still love
you buddy
go [ __ ] yourself what
what taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one